what's up hockey fans NHL 18 is
introducing an all-new three-on-three
hockey experience during their latest
beta NHL threes is a pick-up-and-play
arcade mode where you can play quick
games both online and offline co-op and
competitive NHL threes ramps up the
action with faster skating bigger heads
and more open ice for players to execute
flashy goals are you excited for NHL's
new arcade mode let us know in the
comments below and be sure to subscribe
for more NHL when the games release this
September
[Applause]
players but
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
shut them down
[Applause]
these two teams just can't seem to get
in
that's the door
[Applause]
Oh
easy
tender caring days
[Applause]
great day and finish it
[Applause]
[Applause]
I can't thank you enough for coming out
and part of this great show freeze
action and it's better try safely love
one another and keep both of those team
to join the NHL for the star
99 season
[Applause]
so it's
[Applause]
take the shot Rocha Shane
[Applause]
[Applause]
denies in the glory I say
[Applause]
gets his leg on a cage
[Applause]
I had a great time and I hope you did as
well thanks for coming out and
experiencing that's exciting new game we
call three